there is intense fighting underway right
now in Ukraine as President Vladimir
zielinski visited with troops in the
eastern part of the country MTS Taya
visited Kiev suburb which fell victim to
allege Russian atrocities earlier in
this war
he has his story
the battle for Bak Moots
bruise Russian forces are reportedly
losing up to 100 soldiers a day here
ukrainians are also taking heavy losses
as the fight for the Strategic Eastern
region oh the intensifies on the front
lines President Vladimir zielinski met
with troops to Mark the country's Armed
Forces Day
I wish you to live says if you are alive
it means our country is alive
but at a small Cemetery in the key
suburb of bucha which is still haunted
by the atrocities committed here by
Russian forces
a solemn service for soldiers who have
paid the ultimate price
these are the mothers wives and sisters
of men and women who died in the
fighting
it's an anguish Natalya knows all too
well
her husband and brother are buried here
how are you feeling
I feel pain I cry and I'm empty
I'm trying to come to terms with me but
I can't
I just can't
how to come to terms with the horrors
that have been inflicted on Ukraine's
people is a question few here have
answers for
I
tell them everything that's happening
it's like I'm still waiting for them to
come home
but Natalia knows her husband and
brother won't be coming home like so
many others
for CBS mornings imtions Ukraine